[Music]
so
[Music]
it's seven o'clock i'm der mcmanahan and
this is a sky news special as the war in
ukraine enters its second month
nato eu and g7 leaders hold three
emergency summits in brussels
leaders approved major increases to
forces in eastern europe and pledged to
equip ukraine to fight against russian
chemical and nuclear warfare nato has
never never been more united than it is
today
putin is getting exactly the opposite
what he intended to have as a
consequence of going into ukraine
the heroism
of ukraine
has changed
the geopolitics of europe
vladimir putin has badly miscalculated
and i believe he knows it
meanwhile ukraine's navy claims to have
destroyed a russian landing ship
after weeks of being cut off from all
help the besieged people of mariopol
queue for humanitarian aid
and a warm welcome from the british
families giving refugees a way out from
the war
[Music]
good evening well now it's been
described as one of the most important
meetings in the history of the alliance
nato leaders met in brussels today to
discuss how to help ukraine continue to
defend itself against russia the
alliance announced it will send 40 000
more troops to its eastern flank four
battle groups to slovakia hungary
romania and bulgaria the g7 and the eu
have also been meeting extraordinary
summits taking place in extraordinary
times as concern grows about whether
russia might resort to using chemical
weapons next in ukraine and in brussels
president biden said nato allies had
never been more united
nato has never never been more united
than it is today
putin is getting exactly the opposite
what he intended to have as a
consequence of going into ukraine and
today i'm announcing the united states
are prepared to commit
more than one billion dollars in
humanitarian assistance to help get
relief to millions of ukrainians
affected by the war in ukraine
many ukrainian refugees will uh will
wish to stay in europe closer to their
homes
but we also will welcome 100 000
ukrainians to the united states with a
focus on reuniting families
and we will invest 320 million dollars
to bolster democratic resilience
and defend human rights in ukraine and
neighboring countries
we're also coordinating
with the g7 and the european union on
food security as well as energy security
and the prime minister also pledged more
lethal aid would be sent to ukraine
including 6 000 more missiles and 25
million pounds in funding for ukraine's
armed forces
today i've announced that we in the uk
will send an additional 6 000 missiles
and provide 25 million pounds in
unrestricted funding for ukraine's armed
forces more than doubling the lethal aid
we provided to date
we're bolstering our support for the
nato countries on the front line
sending a new deployment of uk troops to
bulgaria on top of doubling our troops
both in poland and in estonia the
message
that president putin can take from
today's extraordinary meeting of nato
and the g7 is this
ukraine
is not alone
we stand
with the people
of kiev
of mario paul of la viv
and donetsk
and
as president zielenski has said himself
the people of ukraine will prevail
and putin
must fail and he will fail
well nato secretary general jens
stoltenberg said the military alliance
is stepping up its defenses in the event
of a chemical or nuclear attack by
russia
our top military commander general
walters has activated nato's chemical
biological radiological and nuclear
defense elements
and allies are deploying additional
chemical and biological and nuclear
defenses to reinforce our existing and
new packing groups
and in a pre-recorded video message the
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
was clear about what support he wants
from nato
on the 24th of february i addressed you
with a personal
request please help us
shelter our skies in any format protect
our people from russian
bombs and measles we didn't get a clear
answer ukraine doesn't have
powerful
anti-missile defense
and
russia has the superiority in the
skies and they have weapons of mass
destruction
we now is sky's defense and security
editor deborah haynes who's in brussels
so uh let's discuss nato first of all
deborah and maintaining its unity and
bolstering its eastern flank
yes so like you said there's there's two
elements really to this summit there was
what the nato allies can do for ukraine
and also what they can do for themselves
in terms of resetting their entire
defense and deterrence posture they
realize that the the moves that they
made in the wake of russia's first
invasion of ukraine back in 2014 just
clearly haven't been enough it hasn't
stopped russia from launching that
extraordinary intervention in ukraine
and so what you're really sensing here
at nato headquarters is this galvanized
sense of requirement to
invest in their defenses mobilize troops
increased the readiness of troops
warships warplanes in a way that we just
haven't seen um since the end of the
cold war there used to be this
restricting factor which was an
agreement between nato and russia
um that would see that nato wouldn't be
deploying troops um on a permanent basis
uh in in its east uh anywhere near the
sort of where the former soviet sphere
of influence would have been but it
seems that that isn't being um adhered
to as much or given as much weight given
the fact that russia has effectively
ripped up the rule books with what it's
done in ukraine and then as well as that
you've also got the the requirement from
nato allies to help president zielenski
we were told that in the address that he
gave he spoke as well to the nato
leaders here during their morning summit
he didn't actually use the term no-fly
zone he didn't specifically ask for that
he knows that he's not going to get that
from nato they've warned repeatedly that
if they were to impose a no-fly zone
that would require nato jets shooting
russian planes out the sky destroying
russian air defense systems which would
mean a direct confrontation between nato
and russia and that could lead to world
war three something that everyone here
seems very determined to avoid instead
the ukrainian president asked nato to
gift him one percent of all of their
jets all of their tanks in order to help
his military defend their territory and
it's interesting that from the allies
you didn't get a clear response to that
there's a balancing act going on right
now um between making sure they're
increasing the lethality of the weapons
and assistance that they're giving the
ukrainian armed forces in order for the
ukrainian military to be able to contend
with increased lethality on the russian
side um but at the same time not giving
too much that they overstep an invisible
threshold frankly that would then
mean that russia might view the nato
assistance as direct intervention and
would again lead to the same kind of
direct confrontation between nato and
russia
and let's talk more about any potential
confrontation between nato and russia
and could that be sparked then by the
potential
use of chemical or biological or even
nuclear weapons
yeah that's a really good question and
it's interesting isn't it that we
haven't had a specific red line um given
by nato today
the the secretary general was asked
about this um
this specifically in terms of what would
nato do to respond if if russia did
decide to use for example chemical
weapons it's something that the allies
are really worried about they know that
russia has the potential to do that kind
of atrocity which is illegal
under international law and yet they
know too that were they to set a red
line say for example to specifically
spell out that were russia to use
chemical weapons for example that would
trigger a military response by nato in
ukraine then again you are on that slide
path to a full-scale war in europe and
they don't want to set those parameters
i thought joe biden the u.s president's
response again to that exact same
question was really interesting nobody
wants to be pinned down they want to
keep putin guessing and he said that the
u.s would of course respond should um
russia use chemical weapons but he said
that the nature of of the response would
depend upon the nature of the use so
clearly there is a sliding scale here in
terms of um the amount of
of weapons used and the response that
that would then trigger
okay deborah haynes in brussels thank
you
well now let's get the latest analysis
of the situation on the ground in
ukraine skies wilfred frost has the
latest
let's get the latest analysis of the
situation on the ground in ukraine
general sir richard barrons is with me
uh generous richard a very good
afternoon to you uh before we dive into
ukraine itself uh given that nato
leaders of course uh meeting uh during
the course of today we thought we'd have
a snapshot here uh of in blue uh
europe's nato members and and general
sir richard what do you think was
likely the the main point they were
discussing behind closed doors
so there are two very important aspects
the the first is nato is now resetting
how it does deterrence and defense
for the length and breadth of nato with
a very difficult relationship
with russia under president putin in
mind so this is about spending pledges
and increasing the readiness of forces
and the second thing mother more on the
here and now is what do they do to
support the ukrainian military not just
through sanctions but with money and the
continuing the supply of weapons let's
dive in a little bit uh particularly to
the eastern flank of nato and some of
those specific announcements that we did
here uh announced last night and then
confirmed today
so we saw uh announcements today that
they were going to add four more battle
groups to the battle groups that nato
has on its decent flank into slovakia
hungary
romania and bulgaria those battlegroups
be about 1500 to 2000 soldiers each from
a number of nations and are designed to
send a signal of assurance to those
countries and of deterrence to russia
diving in now to the situation on the
ground in ukraine and uh kiev in
particular there's been some talk of
some successful counter-attacks from
ukrainian forces how significant are
those
so they are quite significant in that it
shows that the russian advance around
kiev appears to be continuing to
struggle so we've seen counter attacks
around european and bucharan in those
cases quite small numbers of russian
forces appear to have been encircled and
possibly taken prisoner but what's more
relevant here is we're continuing to see
russia struggling to deal with kiev as
an objective and and it's one indication
of how the russian campaign overall
appears to be in its current format
stalling well let's touch on that
because if we zoom out now and look at
ukraine as a whole we get a snapshot of
how the advance has stalled because
as we stand here on the fourth week at
the end of the fourth week of this war
the shaded areas in red haven't changed
too much this final fourth week you're
absolutely right so we've talked about
kiev and they aren't any closer to
getting into kiev they are able to to
shell it uh in the south the advances
out of the crimea still struggling to
capture mario pole although that is
being battered to pieces and one
imagines they will eventually come to
some sort of conclusion there the
advance we've been talking about on
odessa now for a couple of weeks hasn't
yet really materialized in any sense
we do think that it's still an objective
and we might see that
more movement on the land and from the
sea in due course and in the center
around the donbass
it looks like uh the russians when they
can would try to encircle the effective
ukrainian forces that are there but what
we're beginning to see is russia not
being able to take much more territory
of having to think about doing one thing
at once well rather than several things
at once and the ukrainians being
successful in holding the russian
advances back but not able to push them
out of ukraine this begins to feel like
a stalemate that could last for weeks or
months or even longer general sir
richard barrens thanks so much that's
the latest uh one month into this war
well a short time ago sky sally lockwood
gave us this update from leviev in
western ukraine
in the last month of war more than a
quarter of ukraine's population are now
homeless and
we're meeting people here every day in
la viv in in the west of ukraine who
have fled fighting in search of safety
and they're here you know with their
families whatever they can carry with
their children uh trying to plan what
happens next and many of them have
escaped areas where they've been
subjected to an awful lot
people have arrived here absolutely
exhausted some without phone signal uh
many haven't had internet connections so
in terms of being able to stay
across what's happening in brussels that
is really quite a luxury but certainly
uh any extra help from the west would
very much be welcomed here in ukraine
there is a real sense of
trauma here but of course uh resilience
as well now you just need to look at
that southern city of mariopol that has
been absolutely devastated in recent
weeks uh to see the humanitarian crisis
that is unfolding in this country in
certain areas uh those bombings uh of
mario paul already labeled war crimes
and certainly we've just met
three female generations of one family
who've managed to escape mario pole it
took them four days uh the grandmother
saying that she wouldn't wish their
ordeal even on their russian
enemies and we met another mother with
three children who's arrived here as
well now uh looking
as to what she does next
and she did actually say that she would
like to see the skies closed over
ukraine and that is of course how it's
become known here president zielenski's
calling on nato
to impose a no-fly zone over the country
because while the ground offensives by
russian forces have stalled have been
fairly disastrous compared to what many
suspected at the beginning thinking that
kiev would fall within a matter of days
the government
would be toppled very quickly well none
of that
has happened uh ukrainian forces have
fought back fearlessly and done
extremely well
they've even retaken ground in certain
areas but they are running out of
ammunition they're running out of
equipment and as we heard there
in brussels president zielenski is
calling for more military uh support
here in ukraine he also mentioned the
potential use of phosphorus bombs here
in ukraine by russia now that's not been
verified we haven't had any confirmation
of that but there are two unconfirmed
report reports of phosphorus bombs being
used uh in the outskirts of the capital
kiev and also in the legan the lugansk
region and obviously that is a huge
concern that chemical bombs may
be something that we see uh being used
here in ukraine and of course would uh
be a red line it is against the geneva
convention and it would be considered a
war crime and of course there would be
huge pressure on nato in how they would
respond to that but certainly here in
the western city of la vie where there
have been tens of thousands of families
fleeing for the last four weeks it does
feel quieter today it does feel calmer
there is a sense of confidence that
ukraine will get through this the
concern is at what cost
sally lockwood in
there well the ukrainian military says
it has destroyed a large russian troop
ship in the southern port city of
berdiansk the sky news has located and
verified this video the deputy defense
minister of ukraine says the ship can
carry up to 20 tanks 45 armored
personnel carriers and 400 troops
well in a month of conflict the
southeastern city of mario paul has of
course mourned the brunt of some of the
worst attacks as russian forces have
bombarded civilian targets leaving
people without basic necessities like
drinking water the ukrainian government
as well as the eu the uk and the us have
accused russia of committing war crimes
there but so far the city has refused to
surrender for many residents their only
way out has been to take their chances
and head to saporizia about 140 miles
west our correspondent john sparks has
been speaking to some of the thousands
of people arriving there and has this
story
this unremarkable spot in a place called
zaparisia
means a lot to the people of mario paul
it's a beacon of light in the dazzling
sunshine and it marks the end of a
horrific ordeal
it's really strong bad painful
experience and now we need to start our
life from from the beginning
it's just a it's just a car park isn't
it but it's actually it's more than that
it's sun
sky
so
thanks god they arrive in a procession
of battered looking cars with a sign
saying children in the windows
the journey from mario paul is
relatively short
but it is a dangerous trip and some take
days to complete it
how do you feel
helena and her family have negotiated 15
russian checkpoints
but she and her granddaughter alisa are
safe
i am fine you're fine okay
you've had quite an experience
with
irina and her family took six days to
get here they ran out of petrol halfway
but she couldn't spend another minute in
mariopol
i don't know really how to describe it
because
you don't know will you be alive and i
mean i don't know will your
son will be alive
oh no
one night
he said to me my son he is 10 years old
sorry
one minute
he asked me
mama will you
will i see my birthday in august or no
will be alive and i
didn't know what to say to him
on the other side of the street we found
another convoy of cars hoping to make
the trip back to mario paul
the owners want to pick up family or
friends or bury those killed in the
fighting
alexander's mother lived in a building
that was hit by a shell
and he said he wasn't able to reach her
it's been cold he said very cold i doubt
she's alive
if i find a leg i find a leg but i will
bury her
some families bring their documents and
the clothes on their back
others like the lachenkos have brought
the business
and their business is french bulldogs
and pugs
they've got 50 of them now living in two
vans
you don't have much room back there
36 000 people have passed through this
car park along with a large family of
french bulldogs
their lives have been uprooted their
homes have been destroyed but where
there is life there is hope
john sparks sky news in zappo regia
now just to alert you to our new program
beth rigby interviews and tonight beth
will be sitting down with anisha ashori
who was detained in iran for five years
and released last week along with
nazanin sakari radcliffe beth's also
going to be speaking to the chancellor
rishi sunak that's beth rigby interviews
tonight at 9 on sky news and tomorrow at
8 a.m on sky showcase
and you're watching sky news tonight
coming up the first people matched under
the homes for ukraine are in england
we'll have the latest
[Music]
[Music]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
as it is almost impossible to predict
where these fires will go next
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist metal
are you trying to run me over to fill it
no go away sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart of america's opioid
crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget
christchurch has been changed forever by
what happened
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
now the first ukrainian refugees to be
matched with families in england under
the government's homes for ukraine
scheme have arrived many have had to
leave their families not sure when
they'll see them again
thirty-year-old ilona lemeka was amongst
the first to arrive at stansted airport
and she's been speaking disguised becky
cottrell about fleeing her hometown of
dinipro in eastern ukraine
after a nervous wait elena
hello
this was the first time elona from
ukraine met sarah from bedford
they'll now be living together along
with sarah's husband and children
elona is safe with them but she came
here on her own and this is my husband
saying goodbye to her entire life
you don't understand where you're going
how long time you will be absent in your
family and how long you won't see them
not only on i don't know face time or
something like that and how was it
leaving your husband and your parents
where many speak russian but she knew
she had to get out when a missile
narrowly missed her house
and what would you say to president
putin
sarah will get 350 pounds a month for
looking after elona but she'd do it for
free she even paid for her flight to the
uk
seeing the
desperation uh all these people in these
families it's so hard
for us to comprehend how they would feel
but you can understand when
somebody needs help elona wants to find
work as soon as possible but maybe she
needs to acclimatize first
she came down this morning wearing a
coat and we're inside
settling in for all of them is going to
be awkward and difficult at times but
this family has given illona a way out
of war and there are millions more who
need that becky cottrell sky news
bedford
and plenty more on ukraine sure to
feature in tomorrow's papers we'll have
our press preview and news review from
half past 10 this evening with tonight's
news and tomorrow's headlines joining us
will be the politics editor of galden
magazine moya lothian mclean and the
director of communications with the
institute of economic affairs annabelle
denim
and time now for a look at the weather
and the next few days are going to stay
settled with plenty of continuing
sunshine air pollution levels though
will be pretty high in the east so most
places dry this evening if a bit cold
but some showers are possible those
mainly in southern and eastern scotland
not much change overnight the far north
will have some cloud thickening up a bit
of rain too apache ground frost
developing with some mist and fog around
as well so tomorrow morning almost
unbroken sunshine once that mist and fog
lifts but uh some areas in the north
will be dull and damp
you're watching sky news tonight coming
up as nato meets to discuss the
situation in ukraine is another country
revisiting its own decision not to join
the military alliance
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching sky news
tonight the top stories this evening and
the american president joe biden says
that nato has never been more united as
the alliance pledges to send 40 000 more
troops to slovakia hungary bulgaria and
romania
the ukrainian navy has said it's
destroyed a russian warship in the key
southern port of berliansk
the first ukrainian refugees to be
matched with families in england under
the government's homes for ukraine
scheme are spending their first days in
england
okay uh let's concentrate then on the
help for ukraine that is being discussed
by western leaders in brussels today
nato's secretary general has announced
further support including equipment to
protect against potential nuclear and
chemical attacks another country that
sits on russia's border but is not a
nato member is finland the nordic
country has enjoyed relative peace
despite being outside the alliance
however after the invasion of ukraine
finns may be reassessing that position
uh let's speak then to finland's foreign
minister pekka havisto very good to talk
to you foreign minister and i'm sure you
heard my introduction then so the the
question is are finns revisiting this
decision to remain non-aligned
well good evening to you uh if you look
to opinion polls now after the russian
attack against ukraine there has been a
very dramatic change and majority of the
finnish citizens are now in favor of the
nato
membership and of course this has
triggered and also a process that the
government will issue a white paper on
different security options to the
parliament that these issues will be
discussed
what's your own view
there's a foreign minister of course i'm
i'm standing
behind the current policy we have
in our previous white papers parliament
government has adopted this kind of nato
option that things should be reassessed
if security situation changes in europe
and of course we are
in the middle of very dramatic change
and and
it's at least important to discuss how
we can develop our nato partnership we
have a very close partnership together
with sweden and and this is something
that finland values quite a lot well
given the proximity to russia and indeed
uh the history with russia
finnish people no doubt looking at
ukraine and thinking well
they would not have been invaded perhaps
if they had been admitted into nato is
that the main reason behind the change
in public opinion
well finns are very security orientated
people and then in the autumn there was
this uh migration flow or organized
migration from belarus to against poland
and latvia lithuania the finnish people
were asking what if this happening on
our border and now when we saw the
russian attack against ukraine and
attack against the capital kiev and so
forth things are asking it's a very same
question what if this is happening on
our borders
and particularly people are threatened
by by the new types of weapons the the
possibility of using chemical weapons in
this type of warfare or even using
tactical nuclear weapons you might ask
that we have a quite good conventional
army
against all kind of conventional threats
but the new threats including of course
many hybrid threats are something where
we
certainly need support and and we have
been looking it also through european
union through european unions
common security paragraphs but of course
nato is much stronger in europe on these
issues but do you share that i suppose
it's quite a simplistic analysis that
ukraine might not have been invaded if
it had been admitted into nato and
indeed further back if it hadn't given
up its nuclear weapons
well we can we can speculate on those
issues but of course the
that will be witnessed in europe
attack against
independent country of this scale has
been shocking for all of us and and
this is maybe something that we we did
not expect but but this is happening and
of course this has to change also our
own security assessment just fill us in
a little bit i mean so many people
talking i mentioned there
finland's history with russia and of
course referring in the main then to
that winter war way way back in 1939 and
the analysts are saying there are some
similarities in what the brave finnish
people were able to achieve back then
against the mighty ussr
similar
perhaps in parts to what's happening in
ukraine
well i can see that
of course war in europe is triggering in
many finnish families a lot of memories
and and
not only memories of warfare but also
memories of being evacuated from from
the cities and and being idps in your
own country and so forth so there's a
huge solidarity wave now in
finland and when i'm driving to the
office i can see ukraine flag here and
there and and a lot a lot of uh
clear solidarity towards awkward people
are collecting clothes and medicines and
driving by cars trying to pick refugees
to finland and
this is something that we haven't seen
for for a while
and foreign minister let's talk
diplomacy here and what position is
finland in not being a nato member but
with this proximity in this history with
russia what position is your country in
to help broker a deal given that a deal
has to ultimately be the way
to stop this conflict
of course first of all it's important to
say that we follow all the
european union sanctions and many
finnish companies have stopped their
activities in in russia and so forth due
to the
sanctions this is of course influencing
also to the economic field but at the
same time as you know
uh starting from
president of our republic we have been
keeping four years
contacts we have been talking to
russians and even in this conflict
moment of course trying to convince
russia to stop this uh stupid warfare
and at the same time supporting ukraine
also so that it could be as strong as
possible in the in the talks and i i can
see that the talks are ongoing but of
course
it will need time and and certainly it
will need a support to ukraine to to
stand stand strong in these talks you
mentioned your president there president
inisto now he's known to have a a close
or had a close relationship with
president putin has he been in contact
with vladimir putin recently
well he has had
one long telephone call with putin but
also talking to president macron and
president biden and
prime minister johnson and so forth of
course trying to find a
solution to this crisis we have also
been talking as a foreign minister to
the turks who have been involved in the
in these talks and so forth and of
course you have a very permanent contact
with the humanitarian organizations
working on the ground like the
international red cross which is doing
excellent work in the in the middle of
this missouri
and what shape
i mean if you've got an idea in your
head what shape a deal could look like
will the ukrainians have to swallow the
fact that russia is going to keep crimea
and keep its hands on parts of donbass
and indeed will not be able to join nato
well i think these elements as you
mentioned of course are something that
are requested by
donbass issue crimea
ukraine being in the future neutral
country and so forth maybe issues of the
linguistical minority russian-speaking
people in in ukraine and so forth but of
course this the the result of these
talks depends very much
if ukraine can maintain
their security and can fight back and
that's very
very important at the moment and and
there should be also international
guarantors of this kind of peace deal we
shouldn't leave ukraine alone in these
talks
foreign minister thank you very much
indeed for sparing the time to talk to
us on sky news tonight very much
appreciated
thank you
the foreign minister of finland there
and you're watching sky news tonight
coming up is russia preparing a large
scale assault to try to break the
stalemate in ukraine
[Music]
the risk if afghan girls would not be
educated the future of country will be
more darker than today
the risk of eliminating 50 of afghan
population from their basic rights it
will may not have a good consequence
and
not talking about afghanistan from the
international community side and not
holding taliban accountable that would
be a big mistake which is it's it's it's
going to be happen
of course the women and girls in
afghanistan is not the first time we are
seeing the brutal behavior of taliban
this is the second time but we will find
a way still homeschooling is going on
online school is going on but sooner or
later i'm sure the people of afghanistan
will stand against such a brutality but
this is important which kind of message
we have to deliver to those girls to
those teenagers to the women of
afghanistan to the half of population in
the world and the globe it's not just
only they are suffering we are suffering
our heart is crying just the basic
rights education access to education and
going to school it's not something
asking start from the sky this is just
this simple basic rights which is
paramount have to obey we need to
pressurize them we need to ask them we
need to hold him accountable
from august 15 till now every educated
avalan like to live the country because
of the taliban brutality because the
lack of access to the job because of the
violence because of the misbehavior from
the taliban because of putting
boundaries every single day
unfortunately even women cannot travel
without male
members of their family even men cannot
travel out of the country without
taliban permission
women cannot even go simple outside of
their house and walk on the street
without male guardians that's very sad
and 21st century we have been witnessing
such things if you see the borders of
afghanistan right now it's full of been
packed from the people they like to go
out of the taliban control areas out of
the country it's not like they wish to
go
they have no choice
i'm inzamam rasheed and i'm skies north
of england correspondent telling stories
from this culturally rich region i call
home
[Music]
well now nato secretary general has
announced further support for ukraine
including equipment to protect against
potential nuclear and chemical attacks
but it falls short of the no-fly zone an
aircraft requested by ukraine and there
are signs that the ukrainian military is
beginning some kind of counter-offensive
president zielinski remains in office
and russia has failed in its initial
objective
but are the russian military really
beginning to fail in ukraine here's our
defense and security analyst michael
clark
vladimir putin was going for broke in
trying to conquer a country's biggest
ukraine
but a whole month has passed in a
campaign that was only planned to last a
few days
this map shows russian gains over the
past month you can see some of the
advances but nowhere near what was
expected most of the country remains on
ukrainian control so where has russia
gone wrong
my assessment at the beginning of the
war was that if putin doesn't win
quickly he doesn't win i think that
still holds true
the russians made the fatal mistake they
underestimated their opponent believing
they'd be welcomed as liberators
the russians deployed some of their
elite forces first they failed to hold
their objectives in the face of
ukrainian counter-attacks
the ukrainians have adopted more
flexible formations than classic
battalion and brigade structures
the
fact that the ukrainians have managed to
kill so many generals is remarkable and
it's not just due to phenomenal work by
the ukrainians it's due it seems to uh
the fact that uh
the russians have um communications
problems so
the the generals have to go closer to
the action in order to to see what's
going on i don't know any other war
where so many generals have been killed
in real warfare logistics are
fundamental poor logistics are russia's
achilles heel and a lot of their
equipment is poorly maintained they were
told their on exercises they were not
supplied for a long campaign and their
difficulty in resupply has left them
vulnerable to counter attacks this
stalled convoy of russian vehicles is a
perfect example
in iraq in 2003 the us dominated the air
space from the start
we expected to see the same here but
ukrainian jets and drones are still
flying their commanding control remains
intact russian forces are vulnerable to
air attack
so why isn't the russian air force doing
better russian fast jet pilots um get
somewhere in the region of about 80 to
100 flying hours per year and that
compares pretty badly to western
counterparts an air force like the u.s
air force would often be getting you
know between about 200 200 to 250 life
flying hours a year in a fight squadron
if putin thought the west would remain a
bystander he was very wrong sanctions
and the withdrawal of so many companies
from russia is punishing their economy
severely
and the ukrainians are putting to
excellent use the weaponry supplied to
them by the west these n-law anti-tank
missiles donated by the brits are just
one example
it's become clear that the ukrainians
have good intelligence gathering they're
weaponizing the disillusionment of many
of their slavic brothers in the russian
military
but it would be unwise to underestimate
russia in this conflict military
organizations can learn to adapt and
overcome their failings and if putin
decides to take the wall forward as a
battle of attrition then his military
will do that it means scenes like these
in mariopol
or these in kiev
may be repeated
whoever tries to hinder us and even more
so to create threats to our country to
our people
should know that russia's response will
be immediate and it will lead you to
such consequences that you have never
encountered in your history
putin will keep trying to frighten nato
with statements like this while his
attrition strategy has given time to
work
the longer the battle goes on the more
sanctions will hurt russia and
casualties will mount
that's why now that he hasn't won
quickly he loses
russia's forces might still do well and
win a new variation of putin's war
but if so
he still loses the peace
michael clark with the analysis there so
british intelligence is suggesting that
president putin could be preparing a
large-scale assault in ukraine
as russian forces face something of a
stalemate after the stronger than
expected resistance from the ukrainians
well let's speak now to mark galioti an
expert in modern russia and senior
associate fellow at the royal united
services institute very good to talk to
you mark galiotti and
tell us what might be going on in the
russian hierarchy we're hearing these uh
strange reports of
the disappearance or certainly the
non-sighting recently of the defense
minister and the chief of the general
staff
yes it's an interesting situation and in
part it's precisely because in an
authoritarian regime like this
the boss can never be wrong
so clearly although it absolutely is
down to putin's own misunderstandings of
ukraine that this whole disastrous
initial strategy which michael clark was
telling you about um was adopted but
nonetheless now he has to find
scapegoats and in some ways different
agencies are finding different responses
we've got the federal security service
more as proffering up a scapegoat in one
of their deputy directors
whereas
there is some talk that he might have
the defense minister
exactly my apologies um but at the same
time there is a possibility that this is
simply a diplomatic ailment just to keep
him out of sight so that he doesn't have
to get too involved in the war at the
moment i mean it is clear that this war
is going badly and that's a dangerous
time in an authoritarianism well could
he be getting paranoid or even more
paranoid and fear plots against him and
stalin like start removing the key
individuals
yes and i i think you have to say that
the chances of any such sort of palace
coup at the moment seem very very remote
the russian system has all kinds of
different checks and balances and
different services blocking out and
watching each other but on the other
hand it's clearly been a priority of the
sort of the covert information campaign
that the ukrainians are waging very
effectively and also the west as well is
to try and give all kinds of reasons for
putin to become more paranoid and
precisely turn on his own agencies so i
think this is one of the ways in which
we're seeing this is a war that is being
fought out in very kinetic ways in
ukraine but it's also being fought out
not just in economic sanctions but also
in a whole variety of covert political
campaigns to try and undermine the unity
of the russian state and does he seem to
have a mole or moles within those
security agencies you've been talking
about it seems to be in a a series of
letters leaked from deep within the the
fsb and other agencies and i don't know
you know how sure you are about their
provenance if
they're verified to your satisfaction
but there does seem to be disquiet right
at the heart of those agencies
yeah absolutely and those particular
letters you're referring to yes i must
admit i have some some qualms about
whether they're accurate but the reason
why they're powerful is precisely
because whether or not the letters are
actually coming from some mold deep in
the federal security service it
nonetheless accurately reflects the real
kind of disquiet look remember this is a
system which has encouraged the rise of
ruthless pragmatic opportunists
and that's fine when the system is
working and they are getting all kind of
great opportunities but it absolutely
means that these are people who when
they begin to feel putin is a danger
rather than an opportunity they will
have no loyalty to him as i say we're
not yet anywhere near a kind of tipping
point but it's understandable why putin
may well be feeling worried because he
knows just how carnivorous even
cannibalistic these institutions can be
well let's get to the kinetic part as
you put it there the war itself on the
ground and in the air under sea and i
suppose it's a
tabloid way i'll put it if putin has
miscalculated the question is
does he back down or double down
i think in a way and i'm going to live
down to every expectation of the
woolly-minded academic
both are true i mean on the one hand we
do have a peace process
which is proceeding and there's a
possibility that it'll lead somewhere
though not immediately
but the point is though that putin will
want to have the strongest hand possible
in those negotiations and this is why
we're seeing stepped-up campaign
particularly to take cities like mario
paul because in a way each city he can
take becomes a bargaining counter
so i think we're almost certainly going
to see things get more violent and more
ugly
even if in fact that actually is part of
the process that brings us to a peace
deal but certainly for the next few
weeks it's going to be rough
and mark analyze this for us some the
the threats the continuing threats from
russia to go as far as using nuclear
weapons if russia faces an existential
threat
now russia's definition of what's an
existential threat and nato and the
west's definition
may be pretty different
absolutely and look i have to say that
so far at least all the references to
nuclear forces have really been about
signaling they have been about potential
intimidation
and so in that respect we shouldn't take
it too seriously and certainly even
within russian doctrine
what we're seeing happening in ukraine
would not in any way be considered to be
an existential threat to the motherland
but the problem is that the putin we
have seen in the last month and a half
has not been the putin of old who
despite his bare-chested macho persona
was always actually very cautious very
risk-averse
now we're seeing someone who
in some ways it's more of an old man in
a hurry who's clearly willing to take
big gambles and who clearly feels
viscerally that the battle for ukraine
is not just simply a battle for a
country it is for russia's whole status
as a great power and an independent
sovereign operator on the world scene so
although i still think the odds of that
kind of escalation are still very very
small
they're greater than under normal
circumstances we we could have expected
them mark galioti great talking to you
thank you so much for your analysis mark
aliotti from the royal united services
institute uh now we've just got time for
a quick look at the weather for you
and the next few days are going to stay
settled with plenty of warm sunshine air
pollution levels though will be high in
the east so most places dry this evening
a bit cold but some showers are possible
those mainly in southern and eastern
scotland so little change overnight the
far north though we'll have some cloud
and a bit of rain uh patchy ground frost
again with some mist and fog developing
as well tomorrow morning then almost
unbroken sunshine once that mist and fog
lifts the northern isles though will be
dull and damp though most areas will be
warm again now the temperatures get this
high of 20 degrees celsius around about
68 fahrenheit somewhere in england or
wales the afternoon stays similar but
some fair weather cloud whatever that is
we'll build perhaps giving isolated
showers ireland and northern england
look most at risk from that fair weather
cloud
and you're watching sky news tonight
coming up at 8 o'clock western leaders
discuss what more they can do
to help the ukrainians
[Music]
the